as we've been saying the nurses Union is
meeting the government today for
intensive talks and they've paused next
month's strikes elsewhere the British
Medical Association is sitting down with
health officials as well but it's
understood the health secretary Steve
Barclay won't be at that meeting Dr Emma
runswick is Deputy chair of the BMA and
is with us now hi doctor it's good to
see you so are nurses being given
preferential treatment
I'm not sure that they are because at
the same time as they have announced
intensive talks with the RCN they have
also submitted their evidence to the pay
review bodies suggesting that many
public sector workers including doctors
including nurses should receive only
three and a half percent in next year's
pay round which is not only another real
terms pay cuts of over six percent but
also makes absolutely no effort to
address the real terms pay cuts that
we've had over the last decade or more
for doctors that's a real terms pay-up
of over over a quarter 26 Virginia
Doctors and about 30 for Consultants
nurses in a slightly different position
but I'm hoping that talks today with RCL
and with BMA will produce an offer that
is substantially better than that and is
lesser than insult
okay but nurses are being called in for
the 21st century equivalent of beer and
sandwiches uh you guys have not got
talks with the health secretary have you
not today that's very unfortunate and we
had we had hoped that the health
secretary would come to the meeting
today with the Department of Health and
Social care and but that's those are
questions that you have to ask him
really about whether this is important
enough is it important for him to avoid
72 hours of strike action by Junior
doctors in March and if it is then there
needs to be a significant change in the
approach
I suppose that's why I'm asking you
whether nurses are getting preferential
treatment divide and conquer
no I don't think they are because as
we've seen at the same time as they're
offering talks and they are also saying
that they should receive nurses should
receive another real terms pay cut this
year so I don't think that looks like
especially preferential treatment I
think it looks like a tactic to delay
strike action and it's the same that
they've done to nurses so that to
teachers even they've offered the
teachers talks again on the condition of
council strike action whilst
simultaneously saying that they deserve
another real terms pay cut in the next
pay round so I don't think that that
represents a serious set of offers or a
serious set of talks I think that that's
insulting to doctors nurses and all
other public sector workers should it be
the health secretary who's having these
conversations with you or do you want
the prime minister to get involved now
I think it would be perfectly reasonable
for the Prime Minister and indeed the
chancellor to to get involved with talks
and the Department of Health and Social
care are telling us that there's there's
no additional money and therefore the
decision makers are the chance to learn
the Prime Minister
the the NHS is in a complete crisis and
Workforce crisis waiting list crisis
Staffing crisis
we could do better than this and if the
Prime Minister and Chancellor are
serious about that then they will
support the Department of Health to to
give us serious offers on pay
okay good to talk to you thank you
thank you very much